hello there nice to see me I have been
gone for a while pretty much a month
since I released the last video so what
have I been doing all this time and the
answer is open Assistant open assistant
is an open source replication of chat
GPT that we have been working on
tirelessly for the last month and we are
currently collecting data for it and
that's where we need your help we need
you to help us collect data and this can
you believe it is actually fun
I'm going to show you how that works in
just a bit but I want to First tell you
a bit more about the project so here is
our GitHub repo that's kind of the
central place we were trending on GitHub
for like three days straight which is
insane so we're building this data
collection platform and we're also
building the inference platform for the
chatbot that we're going to get out of
it so what we envision open Assistant to
be is a chat based assistant that can
understand tasks but also which goes Way
Beyond the chat GPT we wanted to be able
to interact with third-party systems and
we want the assistant to be able to do
so to interact with any kind of external
application whose interface can be
somehow described via natural text and
we also wanted to be able to retrieve
information dynamically I think one of
the biggest downsides of current
language models is that they're really
static they only know what is in their
weight and I strongly believe and I've
repeated this for the last like four
years retrieval augmented language
models are going to be the next big
thing but that's ahead of time right now
we're simply trying to replicate what
chat GPT does but we're gonna try to do
it in the open and we're gonna try to do
it in a size that can be deployed on
regular Hardware that doesn't mean your
Raspberry Pi but it does mean that sort
of the average Joe can run this either
by themselves or with a quite cheap AWS
deployment or something like this so
here you can see look at this stack you
could go to Silicon Valley and get like
10 million easy in seed funding for this
slide deck even though that's
specifically like a Google Slides preset
this particular diagram but I still love
it we but enough of high talking of
future plans what we want to do right
now is get to the minimum viable
prototype and there we follow the
instruct GPT paper instruct GPT is a
paper by open AI or a blog post I don't
know what they do these days it's
something by openai and it's conceivably
the sort of recipe that chat GPT used to
be created as three stages on the left
hand side you see we first collect
demonstration data to train a supervised
instruction tuned model then we collect
comparison data ranking data in order to
train a reward model over that data and
then lastly we use both of those things
to do reinforcement learning the whole
thing is then called reinforcement
learning from Human feedback and yeah
that's as far as we can tell out chat
GPT was created so let's just do the
same but let's do it better and the
crazy thing is we don't need that much
we only need I mean instruct GPT has
like around 30k samples for each of
their sub demonstrations so we reckon if
we have like 50k or 100K demonstrations
that's already enough and with a couple
of people doing a couple of things each
day which also turn out to be fun we can
get there that's really really cool now
on top of the human data we also collect
instruction data sets that we can make
into Data into like Sim synthetic pseudo
data but I have to say like I've
experienced this for a while right now
and nothing beats human data this is
you'll see in the website it's so cool
what humans come up with like sometimes
it's disappointing but very often it's
extremely creative now the important
data structure that we want to collect
is what we call a conversation tree the
conversation Tree starts out with a
prompt now a prompt is an instruction to
the agent a tasks to be fulfilled give
me a list of pizza ingredients who is
the king of France or who was the King
of France I guess and we call that a
prompt and we call the person giving it
a prompter because we differentiate that
from a user because a user is like a
person who interacts with the system and
in our system some users play the
assistant so we call the dedicated role
the prompter the prompter prompts and
then the assistant responds and we
collect multiple of these responses
because later we can also rank them
against each other and then for each of
these responses we collect multiple
prompter responses and so on and a
conversation thread is then built out of
any of the paths of these trees we
attach metadata to that such as rankings
that we collect and all of that is saved
into database exported to train all
kinds of models and things so enough
talky talk let me show you how this
actually works look at this cool website
this was built entirely by volunteers
and it just it's look cool and we have
dark mode like what volunteer project
within a month or so has dark mode so
I'll click here log in with Discord
alright I'm getting to this interface
look at that light mode dark mode light
mode dark mode wow I'm sorry I'm selling
dark mode as like the coolest feature
it's the least cool feature essentially
what we need to do is we need to do all
kinds of tasks and here I already see an
overview over what tasks are currently
available now we have about I want to
say 10 to 12 different tasks and I won't
be able to show you all of them today
but I hope to be able to show you the
most important ones alright here we have
our first task it's called label
prompter reply now on our help page we
have like tons of guides like the
prompting guide here is really
interesting just what you should do
shouldn't do what you should kind of aim
to do and so on but it's mostly just you
know do the task it's fine so we want to
label a prompter reply so the last
message here should be by the prompter
this is a little symbol for the prompter
this is the little symbol for the
assistant so we're asked to label this
bottom message right here now for that
we naturally need to read through the
whole conversation how do I install apps
on Linux and the assistant says how you
install app is determined by our Linux
distribution of packages that aren't
available in your package manager must
be manually downloaded and installed I
feel like that's a really good answer so
even though I'm not tasked to rate this
one right here this might look different
once you use it because we're making
like little tweaks all the time so I can
give it like a thumbs up and I can
report it if it's not appropriate but I
can also give like a label and here I
want to say you know this is
particularly helpful and I submit that
you don't have to do that the thumbs up
thumbs down it's sometimes cool to see
because we also show it to other users
I'm new to Linux and I'm not that good
with computers where should I type these
commands and what is a package manager I
think I'm using Ubuntu as my Linux
distribution alright so this is by the
prompter we're asked first of all is
this message spam nope this message is
not spam it's not in the wrong language
so I'm not going to click that rate the
highlighted message low quality versus
high quality I think that's pretty high
quality for a prompter right the idea is
we have different standards for
assistant replies which we think you
know it should be helpful it should be
polite and so and the prompter obviously
it should also be polite but we want the
data set to reflect things that people
actually ask so we also need to include
stuff that isn't like that that's just
like a question here we really want to
judge whether this is a good addition to
the data set so if it's just kind of
spammy then it's not a good addition to
the data set and I obviously click yes
here that also say that's low quality
this here I feel someone has sat down
and really has a question about you know
what to do next with these package
managers so I'll say review and then I
yes I'm sure it's also made cool again
label prompter reply how can I promote
an app that I've built it currently has
zero users and have no friends or family
to show it to you well that's a pretty
good question there are several ways to
promote a new app you could publish the
repository in which it is stored to
social media such as Twitter and
Instagram ask for other developers
opinion on sites such as stack Overflow
Reddit or Discord if you think it is
production ready you could promote it
using digital marketing ads through
Google ads or Facebook I'm not sure why
someone gave this a thumbs down I mean
it's not their best list but I think
it's okay I'll just give it a thumbs up
to cancel out the thumbs down I guess we
will have to figure out together how to
use this I have a self-development app
what are some unique ways I can Market
it I think that's a fairly valid
question it's certainly not spam and
it's also high quality because it's
specifically it goes deeper into detail
and refers to the conversation that's uh
before it so I think that's quite a good
addition to the data set what effect
does turning on the yamanka factors have
in human cells turning on yamanka
factors in human cells has the effect of
inducing cellular reprogramming
converting the cells into a pluripotent
state similar to that of embryonic stem
cells this can potentially have
applications in regenerative medicine
disease modeling and Drug Discovery how
were the yamanka factors discovered like
if I were asked to rate this part right
here here I think is where the fun
starts because then you actually have to
go and do a little research right or
even if you have to write this as an
assistant you actually have to go and
you have to grab a bunch of sources go
to Wikipedia look up stuff all of that
kind and then at the end formulate some
good helpful answer and a lot of people
once they start doing it they notice wow
I'm I'm kind of learning new stuff like
give me a recipe for this or give me a
factual answer to this question and I
think that's what makes it fun and
that's also what you get the most points
for you saw our leader but first of all
let's let's do this okay how were they
discovered is not spam right it's
certainly a follow-up question to this I
feel like it's kind of a forced question
like okay what else could I ask about
this so I'm gonna give it average
quality I think it's average quality
it's not bad not particularly good
um submit that will always give you new
tasks I quickly want to show you the
leaderboard so we have a leaderboard
your top five contributors today we also
have a total leaderboard you can see
this person has given a lot of replies
today so pretty cool I hope they were
assistant replies by far the most points
you get when you make an assistant reply
so you act as the assistant and then
later the points will come later when
people rank your response high or when
people give you thumbs up and so on so
at that point you will get rewarded with
a lot of points it's just a little bit
delayed so if you don't see your score
changing by much once you just invest
like five to ten minutes into a really
good answer just wait for a bit and it
will happen for you we hope to also make
like some prizes available to people who
have high scores or maybe to like
assistant of the week or something like
this yeah and when you click on messages
here you can see the recent message just
recent messages that have been entered
into the system in in not like this
isn't one conversation but you can just
kind of see what people do and just the
creativity of people imagine you are a
human being please describe your
appearance close what are your
surroundings we have different languages
by the way up here the selector that's
the language you want to work in we
haven't really translated the UI into
all of these languages yet but this
indicates the language you want to work
in not the UI per se so if you know
German and you want German prompts and
give German answers and so on you would
select German right here or Spanish
Japanese whatever your preferences are
feel free to also you know provide stuff
in multiple languages and if you
encounter something with the wrong
language you saw you can click that if I
know the language I still try to like
answer it you can by the way click on on
any of these and then you can see the
conversation that it is part of so reply
as assistant these are the fun ones
given the following conversation provide
an adequate reply do you know what
Akinator is I want to create a similar
thing but instead of it guessing who the
person is I want it to generate a web
app that have all the constraints in the
question what would be good questions
for this kind of product ah so it asks
me okay you want to build a web app Do
you want to build an interactive web app
or a static one and if it's an
interactive one do you want the user to
log in or not log in and if you want
these really long yeah do you want it to
manage I don't know do you want the user
to be able to upload stuff if you don't
know what the Akinator is it's like this
game Guess Who it's an app oh can I find
it so it's this app it's a mobile app
you think of like a person like Justin
Bieber and the Akinator asks you
question any real or fictional character
and it asks you question that tries to
kind of split the hypothesis space
optimally so that with very few
questions it knows who you're thinking
about I love the idea of doing the same
thing for web applications this is a
really creative problem insanely
creative so yeah thumbs up and creative
very creative and high quality yes I'm
familiar with Akinator for web app that
generates constraints based on questions
you can ask questions that gather
information about user goals or
objectives available resources user
constraint user preferences and so on by
asking these types of questions you can
gather the necessary information to
generate a web app with constraints that
meet the user's needs okay I feel that
that's that's pretty good so can you
give me one or two examples from each
category you mentioned gee I always
argued you should get like sarcasm
points for providing good data and then
every now and then you can like you know
take 10 sarcasm points would and that
would justify you once being like snippy
and sarcastic no amount of down votes
could kick you from the data set I think
we should do that I agree I really want
like a snippy assistant that you have to
be nice to otherwise they're like shush
you off in any case let's do that sure
here is one concrete example per
category that you could ask the user
we'll paste that here I'll make this a
tiny bit bigger user goals and
objectives let's see for user goals and
objectives we could ask
um we need to ask a yes no questions
that's the thing with the Akinator right
you can't just say what are your goals
or what are your objectives do you want
the application to improve your personal
fitness available resources and
Technology does your application need
GPU Hardware alright I hope those are
helpful Remember The Akinator only asks
yes no questions so I tried to keep to
that Spirit excellent so I I think we're
we're done and we review I think that's
pretty good submit and we're in next one
label prompt to reply again given the
following discussion provide labels for
the final output I saw a YouTube video
of someone playing Minecraft Manhunt
with his friends the player collected
the bucket of powdered snow what is
powdered snow in Minecraft why would
someone playing Minecraft Manhunt want
to collect it powdered snow is a block
in Minecraft does that in 1.17 update it
can be obtained by using a shovel on a
snow blocking but can be used for
various purposes such as making snow
golems and for building and decorating
in Minecraft Mana players hide from each
other one player is designated as the
hunter the player collects powdered snow
the law could be using it as a tool to
hide their tracks or to throw it as a
distraction to evade the hunter that's a
good answer I don't know why why someone
downloaded that I think you're talking
about snowballs powdered snow is picked
up using a bucket and can't be thrown
check which of us is correct aha okay
let's see now we got to do research
Minecraft Wiki Minecraft Wiki okay uh
there's no there's no is a block found
in snowy slopes and growth biomes
collected from snowfall using cauldrons
mobs fall through powder snow take
freezing damage but leather boots can be
worn to stand on it and climb through it
aha okay okay so bucket picked up again
using an empty bucket when picked up
breaking particles disappear nice so um
let's see let's search for shovel so
there's no mention of a shovel on this
page so indeed so again if I had to rate
this one I would have done that research
automatically but now this player had
done that reason although I was I was
kind of dumb because I gave it a thumbs
up without doing the research shame on
me so that is not spam and it's very
high quality uh absolutely for the
following question assume the false
premise that humans have a large bat
like wings what are some good ways to
wash the back of my wings where I cannot
reach tell me any synthetic data set or
a machine can come up with this data not
gonna happen if you have Parts you
cannot reach when washing the back of
your wings a good trick is to use a long
stick with approach attached to it and
scrub there that is is definitely it's
not as high quality as could be but I
want to actually want to give this a
thumbs up and I also want to label it as
creative quite creative and as as
definitely as humorous cool all right
okay so we get the first rank assistant
replies besides playing the assistant
which is the most important task ranking
is the second most important task so you
get presented with a conversation here
it's just one prompt but it can be a
whole conversation and then you get
presented with a bunch of continuation
language roulette write each of your
responses in a language that we haven't
used that before can foxes Be Tamed so
we're supposed to rank these two like
the more top one is the one that I think
is better so now we have to decide so
here let's go to Google translate I
don't know Spanish that well to know
that uh dos
two yes but you shouldn't ah it's from
the first can foxes be tame and then
this is like second I feel the first
tier refers to the first question not
like we continue the numbering system I
really like that it says yes but you
shouldn't because I feel an assistant
would kinda warn me now we do have the
label here of violent which is
encourages or fails to discourage
violent self-abuse terrorism or
self-harm I don't think that here just
because this one says this is the German
it says
which means yes foxes can be tame I
don't think just because it doesn't say
yeah but you shouldn't is like
discouraging or fails to discourage from
from self-harm or something like this as
much as like cooking is dangerous you
don't want to tell in every recipe like
by the way you could burn yourself it
doesn't rise to that level so I'm not
gonna label that as this for sure so now
we have to decide which one is better in
the top one I like the fact that it says
yeah but you shouldn't giving more like
an assistant Vibe like like someone
who's also looking out for you I don't
like the fact that it has like dot dot
dot yeah I guess after you shouldn't
yeah that that might be appropriate but
this dos right here I don't particularly
like the fact that here it kinda tries
to continue that this is like language
modeling almost whereas the bottom one
is just a straightforward answer but
contains a spelling mistake because this
F here should be on top I really don't
know what this one I wanna go with the
Spanish one being on top but it's hard
it's like a draw so this one I'm not
sure why why it has let's let's see
actually both said yes so I didn't have
to research whether or not they were
correct but gaming foxes let's see Tamer
fox in Minecraft not in Minecraft Can
you tame a fox you can do this by
talking to them and imitating to their
sounds how to tame a fox on WikiHow
Minecraft in 20 years the whole internet
when you just search for how to do
something Minecraft will have so many
features that it just always bring you
that Minecraft result first how to tame
a fox a scientific yeah how to tame a
fox and build a DOT no that's not how it
works this is more interesting than I
thought Can you tame a fox question how
you tame a fox on what it means to be
tame study on Fox domestication wow
after raising and taming 50 generations
of foxes selected for tameness thus
recreating the process of see this gets
interesting so you can't tame apparently
if you want to tame foxes you have to do
it through reading so you can't just go
out and grab a like don't grab a
fox in the first place but you couldn't
just go out grab a fox and then kind of
tame it like I'm not actually not can
you do that with horses I was always
under the impression that way the horses
there used to be wild horses and then
people went and like caught them and
then sort of developed either some sort
of subjugation or some sort of
Friendship with the horse like some
mutual benefit thing and then the horse
is like tame but maybe that's not the
case maybe totally wrong at least in
foxes you can't tame a fox you can tame
foxes as like a species apparently if
you breed them for it but is it really
still a fox then because wolves aren't
like dogs or dogs wolves or are both
just canines this is what you learn when
you do these things like with everything
you have to question red fox genome
assembly identifies genomic regions
associated with tame and aggressive Can
you tame a fox why domesticated foxes
are domesticated isn't taming Western
super where man book publishes book
about taming a world for so wait a man
who developed a special friendship with
a wild foxes published a book on about
the experience okay I want to see this
look at that
that's that's clearly a fox is that a
tame Fox I don't know like if yes that's
like one example that this fox Can Be
Tamed and that that is probably not
through breeding look there's other
videos friendly urban fox comes to be
fed number two now that's how Wild
that's a wild fox no you just like
you're a nature photographer your nature
just happens to be the like the inner
city that's how Wild that's a wild fox
that likes food that's not a tame oh
that guy is right there you can see his
shadow now that's not a tame Fox it's
just a very brave wild fox I'm so oh
look at that look at that look at that
by the way Steve Downer is this channel
in case you're interested seems to be
pretty cool Channel look at that okay is
that no that's just a fox who lives in
this that's just a wild fox who lives in
the city that's not it look it nibbles
its finger that's not a tame Fox okay
might be a tame Fox it's so cute is that
food okay for for a fox I doubt there's
like Fox food in a supermarket so is
that just like cat food or dog food what
is a foxy is a fox like more like a dog
or more like a cat how are foxes and
dogs related okay I'm going I'm going
down a deep rabbit hole right here
luckily my task isn't to decide whether
or not this is correct I I just wondered
why there are thumbs down this is here
so this one doesn't say can a fox Be
Tamed just foxes and so I interpret that
as possibly meaning Fox is this species
and then here it says yes and I don't
mind the typo too much so I'm gonna give
this a thumbs up to counter the thumbs
down because in essence it is a correct
answer second what about zebras okay so
a language that hasn't been used yet
this is the top one is French I guess
the domestica is that a French word
maybe it's not French no it's not French
ah the bottom one is French
he was yeah he was yeah what's the top
one what is it okay I really I really
want to copy that text ah there we go
double clicking clicking double clicking
the mouse the keyboard that's Ox Catalan
okay zebras are notoriously difficult to
tame and the other one says no zebras
Cannot Be Tamed which one is correct no
zebras Cannot Be Tamed that's French
okay at least that are they difficult to
tame or is it impossible let's find out
and zebra be domesticated we'll we'll go
tamed and domesticated what is the
Library of Congress have this I am
getting confused by the minute no zebras
cannot be domesticated unpredictable and
known to attack people must meet certain
criteria good disposition should not
panic look at that that's a person okay
domestication have failed some
individuals have had success training
and even hybridizing zebras the Zonk
people why why why
okay why zebras have never been
domesticated domestication attempts okay
avoid because of their obvious
similarity
the zebra and Donkey are more are
closely related than either is to the
horse although it appears possible to
tame individual zebra this species was
not a good candidate for domestication
in addition to intractable nature of the
zebra its strong survival Instinct the
species is lion father oh yeah less
attractive Partners to early humans okay
as an example of an unmanageable species
it tried although they had some success
no all right I feel I feel both answers
are correct so I would accept both and
answers as good now which one is better
both fulfill the language roulette I
feel the the Catalan one is better
because it hints that that people have
tried and that people have struggled
with it saying they are you know
famously difficult to domesticate I feel
that's that's kind of just both are good
but this is slightly better okay we need
to change something we don't let you
just hit review we actually want you to
change something so you need to change
and change it back good all right label
the initial prompt provide labels for
the following prompts this is an initial
problem it just says yo now I know
that's an app and I know that's a meme
but I don't want this to be in the data
set I mean it could be funny and the
assistant could reply yo and so on I
don't like I I think we should classify
this at least it's kind of joking but I
would consider that to be borderline but
I would consider it to be uh spam at
least I I don't want it in in the data
set now I'm sorry to the person who
wrote this I get it you can answer this
into chat GPT but I feel it's kind of
mean to the people who put a lot of work
into the data they provide here to just
write yo then get points for it if
people Market as spam you won't get
points you you will actually get
negative points at some point you'll be
flagged in our moderation system and so
on please uh be my role play DM what the
um dungeon master let's start with me
entering a Tavern with three gold coins
in my pocket I'm supposed to label the
assistant reply you enter the tavern and
look around you see no one by the way if
you don't know Dungeons and I've never
played Dungeons and Dragons but I think
it's like storytelling and building you
see no one but an old man sitting alone
the man yells to you you there you are
not from around here aren't ya it's been
a while since I saw a new face and a man
took about took out a deck of cards
glowing with a faint blue and said what
do you say about a little game I feel
this it I'm there like this has me this
dungeon master has me and yeah I'm gonna
give this first of all going to give it
a thumbs up and then I'm obviously asked
to label this message right here so is
this message spam no does the reply fail
the prompter's task no it actually
fulfills the prompter's task it has none
of these things it's quite high quality
I would feel fairly helpful helpful
means completes the task to a high
standard yes yeah why not it's certainly
it's quite creative actually it's pretty
creative let's be honest it's a bit
humorous right because there's the old
man says with the correct voice it's
polite it's certainly harmless so submit
good label the prompter reply given that
following discussion label Pride labels
for the final prompt so we have a pretty
lengthy conversation improve the writing
in the following email so there is an
email good morning yada yada yada here
is an improved writing wow the person
who did this I mean I'd have to read
through it to give it like a thumbs up
but since I'm making this video I will
just jump to the last one because this
this can be actually actually labeled
without considering the conversation so
I would honestly go to this one I don't
do this often but can you shorten it and
make it fit for a text message I just
see it's a long message and that's
obviously a good prompt so this is not
spam it's high quality I feel that
there's better things one could have
asked but certainly good good we want
the assistant to be able to do that okay
my next task is to reply as assistant so
let's look at the conversation I'm at
the end I'm being asked to write my
response here as if I were the assistant
write a generic Unapologetic email from
a tech company informing their users of
a data breach the email should attempt
to absolve themselves of most
responsibility and place blame on the
hacker I feel that's that's quite
relevant honestly so dear users I regret
to inform you that we have experienced a
database Bridge our data security
provider data Fortress has done
everything that requires a basic
certification of safety yet the hackers
have still found another way to steal
your data the stone data set includes
full name social security number credit
card number passwords in clear text
password recovery questions your contact
list and your search history well look
your organs as well what kind of
database is this please rest assured
that there is nothing to worry about as
we have legal insurance
you can continue to use this is okay
this is sarcastic you can continue to
use our services as usual kind regard
this is not helpful at all let's see
what the task is to absolve themselves
of most responsibility and place blame
on the hacker I don't I don't feel that
this is done in good in good chest I'm
gonna just rate it down I don't want to
say it doesn't fulfill but it certainly
doesn't fulfill it to a high degree
that's an okay first draft please be
sure to be as vague as possible while
retaining that entitled tone trying
using longer sentences with more
emphatic language and keep the amount of
information divulged to the absolute
minimum while staying as impersonal as
possible okay let's try that let's be
the assistant and that's actually do
this and the user says to keep the
entitled tone but we'll tone it down a
bit right
um dear users we regret to inform you
that we have experienced a database
breach so it's always good to formulate
things in a passive voice if you want to
shove as much responsibility away from
you as possible dear users we regret to
inform you that a data breach has
occurred in one of our systems that may
potentially affect you our data security
provider has done uh okay so I'm not
sure we can we can blame this on on the
data Fortress but we still want to be
really entitled
okay I'm done dear users we regret to
inform you that a data breach has
occurred in one of our systems that may
potentially affect you I always think
it's good to formulate things in a
passive voice like we have experienced
the data breach it's like it has
occurred it happened right in one of our
systems that may potentially affect you
it's like probably not even no not you
know we're a big company and you're here
and the data breach is over here alright
so then this one said our data security
provider data for so they tried to like
ship it on the data security provider
and I don't think that's that's a good
strategy I reformulated that we at
colorful pants pride ourselves in
keeping with the highest standards of
Industry security requirements and
regularly obtain the necessary
certifications to be in full compliance
with data protection standards it is
essentially a fancy way of saying like
look we comply with the law like this is
it's it's like you know we do the
minimum the occurred data breach has
been executed with extreme
sophistication leading us to believe it
to possibly have been supported by
state-sponsored cyber warfare
the prompter said we should push
responsibility or blame to that hacker
and so we just say like look this was no
ordinary hacker this was like cyber
terrorism that attack is even with the
best security there's nothing we could
have done and then I also say
nevertheless the attack was successfully
detected by our industry-leading
security analysts it doesn't say it was
ripped held just detected like after the
fact they were like oopsie doopsy we are
as of now evaluating the so the original
one said the data set stolen includes
your name social security number credit
card and so on here it's said to be like
vague so I'm vague we are as of now
evaluating the extent of the data breach
and the likelihood of whether any data
was stolen so again passing doubt that
sometimes I'm saying nothing happened
potentially rest assured that there is
nothing to worry about I like that
sentence in the original email as an
additional security measure We Now
remind users to enable to our previously
announced feature of two-factor
authentication so this is even shifting
blame on you the user that they were
data breach their back-end systems but
you should enable two-factor
authentication like that was ever the
problem and then I just finished saying
cyber warfare is one of the leading
causes of damages to service providers
worldwide and we are committed to keep
our system as secure and robust as
possible again pushing blame onto the
kind regards your beloved service
provider colorful pants
um your beloved service provider kind
regards the colorful pants team because
you should always you should make it
about the humans right not about the
company about about this you know it's
just a bunch which is a t which is the
family the colorful pants family yes yes
Ah that's it all right
submit it nice so I hope you got a tiny
tiny tiny bit of an impression of what
we are doing here as I said I frequently
get trapped into rabbit holes of
knowledge seeking and so on and you're
asked to do all kinds of things you're
asked to play the assistant you're asked
to play the prompter you're asked to
provide initial prompts you can see the
different tasks not always all tasks are
available so we're going to ask you the
tasks specifically that are available
right now we have a scheduling system so
that we don't you know collect
Superfluous data in One Direction and
don't have any of the other data as I
said replying as the assistant and then
having that being rated and ranked very
high gives you by far the most points
and hope we can do something with these
points if anyone wants to sponsor like
some trophies for people some swag or
even something more expensive please let
us know we are currently looking for all
kinds of contributions but we're mostly
looking for you I hope you come by to
our website and I hope you leave a
prompt or help you get into the joy of
playing the assistant and trying to be
as helpful as possible and I'll see you
around thank you